hoping to take advantage of the S P's
woes is Scottish labor and we can now
speak to their leader that's anasawa who
is in Glasgow for us and thank you for
being on the program this morning and
firstly I just want to get your reaction
to the partygate video obtained by the
mirror should the two people attending
had their honors revoked
look absolutely and I think if Rishi
sunak wasn't so weak you should be
withdrawing the entire honors list from
Boris Johnson I think that video was
disgusting it's shameful it's going to
anger people right across the country
and it just feels like the conservative
party wants us to relive that trauma day
after day week after week and frankly I
think people are getting disgusted by it
so he should show leadership he should
be so weak he should withdraw that
honors list and these people should
apologize it's completely and utterly
disgusting
and now I can see why labor decided
decided for interview this weekend she'd
been polling pretty well in Scotland
you've recently won a local government
by-election in bellshill you must be
feeling pretty chipper
well look we're making good progress but
we're not complacent our feet are firmly
on the ground we've still got a lot of
work to do but I remember speaking to
you two years ago Sophie when I first
became leader of the Scottish labor
party and we were 32 behind the s p in
the opinion polls now to be neck and
neck is of course phenomenal but we've
still got work to do I am still
determined to do the work in every town
Village and Community across our country
to persuade people why the labor party
is back why we need a UK labor
government again but also why we need
change here in Scotland and actually the
last two weeks in British politics and
Scottish politics has proven it you've
got two political parties and utter
meltdown we've got an economically
illiterate modeling bankruptory party in
Westminster and you've got an
incompetent dysfunctional SMP government
here in Hollywood and in the face of
that people want change and now labor is
the only party of change both in
Scotland and across the UK
I can totally see why you are hoping to
benefit from the woes of the SMP as you
say it's pretty extraordinary to see
what's happened in the last couple of
years in Scottish politics
my question is are there any
circumstances where a labor government
would Grant a second referendum on
Scottish independence
look there is not going to be a
referendum on Independence in the next
part would be very clear about that we
want to make kierstarmer the Prime
Minister for the whole of the UK it
would not make sense for us to say we've
had a period of chaos after 13 years of
the conservatives 16 years of the SNP in
Scotland but we're going to plunge our
country into chaos again at the same
time I recognize people want change I
guess this is what I'm having a slight
difficulty with right because you know I
can see why the recent issues with s p
would make people want to vote labor
want to vote for change but if you
believe in Scottish independence why
would you vote for Scottish labor when
you are ruling out another Independence
referendum in any circumstances
but I'll tell you why Sophie so when
support for Independence was low the SNP
was still able to persuade people the
support of being part of the UK to vote
for them because people wanted change
and they wanted a different kind of
government and I'm really clear there
isn't a majority for Independence that
isn't a majority for the referendum but
there is also not a majority for the
state is cool but there's an
overwhelming majority in Scotland and
across the UK for change so I say
directly to people who may have voted
SMP in the past who may still support
Independence who may have voted for
Independence in the referendum I don't
support Independence I don't support a
referendum we may disagree on the final
destination for Scotland but we can all
agree we need to get rid of this rotten
Tory government so let's go in this part
of the journey together transform the UK
damage allow us to demonstrate that we
can make the UK work for every part of
our country whether that is Scotland
Wales England or Northern Ireland and
let's change our country together that's
a positive offer and that's when I'm
confident making come the future
by-election
oh I want to talk a bit about
the seas because labor wants to ban new
drilling licenses in the North Sea now
of course that is creates a lot of jobs
in Scotland right it's a big part of the
economy are you comfortable with the
policy and have you been making any
representations to kirst armor about it
look I think we have won the argument
and won the case for a positive policy
that's going to deliver the green
transformation for Scotland and indeed
the whole of the UK our energy policy is
going to be driven by four key
objectives the first is more jobs not
fewer jobs the second is lower bills not
higher bills third energy security so
we're not relying on imports from
despotic regimes like Russia but also
climate leadership there is going to be
a leader somewhere in the world why not
Scotland why not the UK labor is going
to make sure that we deliver that Green
Revolution Endeavor that leadership
in a couple of days there is no Cliff
Edge there is no turning off of the tap
oil and gas will play a significant role
for decades to come what we're talking
about is working in partnership with the
industry to actually deliver the Green
Revolution not just talk a good game
like we have from our two governments
right now I just want to talk about a
couple of those points you make because
you say it's going to create more jobs
Labor's green policy well that's
indisputed by some and also energy
security it feels interesting that
you're saying it's going to improve
energy security when you're shutting off
at some stage even if you say there's
not gonna be a cliff Edge domestic
energy production now the head of GMB
says your policy is naive he says you
can't control where green renewable jobs
are because of geography I just want to
read you what he's told this program he
said you know our members in the energy
sector and the construction sector
aren't stupid we've been promised tens
of thousands of jobs in the UK but the
truth is those jobs have been created
anywhere but the UK the infrastructure
has been built in China and Indonesia
anywhere really but Britain are you
naive
well Gary Smith is absolutely right
we've had over a decade of promises from
our UK Tour de government and a Scottish
SNP government to say that we were going
to have a Renewables revolution in this
country and create 120 000 jobs those
jobs haven't been created we have as an
incoming labor government the reason why
we're different is because we will
actually not just talk a good game we'll
actually deliver in government and the
prime example of that is the Great
British Energy company GBE will be there
to make the Strategic Investments to
give confidence to the industry and the
private sector to to leverage in that
money to actually realize that ambition
and that hope this is good for Aberdeen
good for the Northeast good for Scotland
and good for the UK and that is a very
very positive plan for example we'll
partner with local authorities we'll
partner with develop devolve governments
in order to partner and leverage in
community buy-in into these projects so
they can benefit from those projects and
we're going to make sure that we don't
make the same mistake the Margaret
Thatcher made with the mining industry
where entire communities were decimated
and many people never went on to work
again we are not going to make the same
mistake in the Northeast we're not going
to make the same mistake with oil and
gas we're going to build a genuine
partnership and we're going to back up
our works with meaningful action to
transform our country
okay and one other question on labor
policy and kirst Thomas you turned on a
previous pledge to scrap University
tuition fees obviously there's no
tuition fees in Scotland I want to know
your personal view on this should
students pay University tuition fees
well look I believe in Devolution I
don't support tuition fees in Scotland
but I'm in charge of what happens in
Scotland not what happens in England and
Wales it's for a cure to decide the
policy in England around tuition fees
and it's for other colleagues elsewhere
in Scotland we don't support tuition
fees but we still recognize that we have
got a big problem we have seen financing
and funding for further and higher
education be decimated in Scotland so we
will need to have a progressive policy
going forward that predicts no tuition
fees but also leverages and money into
our further education our colleges our
universities to make sure every child is
able to maximize their full potential so
we are looking at at what proposals they
would be come the next Scottish
Parliament election in 2026 but no we do
not support tuition fees in Scotland
okay just finally polling polling shows
that labor is heading for government if
it um comes across in the next election
but perhaps a minority rather than a
majority government now in Scotland
coalitions
I'm just laughing something because I'm
not sure which polling people are
looking at all this talk of coalitions
actually what happens is if we saw the
poll that's in the Sunday Times in
Scotland today where labor is on 34 and
the S impure on 34 it actually means the
lead we need across the UK is less than
seven or six points so polling is not
suggesting there's going to be a
coalition we're not complacent though
we've still got work to do okay
labor hasn't formed a majority
government with less than 40 seats in
Scotland since the 1950s so is that what
you're aiming for 40 seats in Scotland
look I want as many seats as possible in
Scotland but I think it's very very
clear when Kirsten became leader three
years ago nobody thought we could win
the next general election when I became
leader two years ago nobody thought
Scottish labor could gain significant
seats I think here is demonstrating that
we can win a majority labor government
and I think we're demonstrating in
Scotland the labor is back on the pitch
and competing again and I'm really
confident that we will deliver the
majority labor government but we're
going to do it by building a partnership
with people right across this UK for
change not the same old same old but the
tour is in the SMP who won more division
in chaos okay thanks very much for being
on the program from the very beautiful
looking glass guy my pleasure